the impact of the pandemic on a mental
health of Canadians is still being
measured but we know social isolation
uncertainty about the future is having
an impact and it's especially acute in
indigenous communities
a new survey this week from stats Canada
found 60% of indigenous people say their
mental health has worsened since the
onset of physical distancing measures
overall 38 percent reported fair or poor
mental health that's 22 percent higher
than in the most recent Aboriginal
peoples survey well before Kovan 19 too
many young indigenous people were crying
out for help as Jeff simple tells us
there's at least one new resource now
offering help that's a phone call away
Ashley Cummings childhood photos carry
mixed emotions every day the good times
growing up in Nunavut snowmobiling with
her parents and the tough times as a
teenager losing several cousins and
friends to suicide suicide has been a
very prominent part of my life for well
since I was a young child as an E nuke
she knows all too well how the suicide
rate among Inuit is one of the highest
in the world almost 10 times the
Canadian average and when she was 16 she
almost became one of those statistics
cuz it was just such a very visceral
pain that I was being or I guess I was
almost subjecting myself through because
I didn't know how to deal with any of it
but she found a lifeline in the form of
a text message conversation with an
anonymous volunteer from Kids Help Phone
they were able to figure it out and help
me take the advice and listen and and
get me out of that crisis mode thank you
for calling Kids Help Phone how can I
help you
the Canadian charity has provided
counseling services for over three
decades and launched a new program last
year targeting indigenous youth looking
of course a service use and doing
everything we can to ensure we're
reaching indigenous young people where
they live and and that our services are
meeting their unique needs the manager
of the program called finding hope says
they're expanding and promoting their
services in indigenous communities such
as pine house Saskatchewan the remote
northern village is home to breathtaking
beauty and terrible poverty Kids Help
Phone is partnering with a local
photography club helping youth to see
the world through a different lens
Photography saved my life and in the
Beauty seeing the beauty through a lens
and instead of looking at the past you
know that and going through the rough
times again for
many First Nations maintain Inuit kids
across Canada they don't have access to
health or mental health services or
supports on a regular basis Kids Help
Phone offers support remotely 24/7 by
phone online chat and text message if
young people's eyes are on a screen
right now then that's where the mental
health supports need to be at the start
of the year they were receiving more
than a thousand text messages per month
from indigenous youth and that was
before the biggest mental health crisis
the organization has ever seen
go home and stay home this is what we
all need to be doing
and I just know how stressful it is for
a healthcare system for my colleagues
and for families the kovat 19 pandemic
and locked it saw demand for kids help
phone services skyrocket more than 1500
cries for help
calls and messages every day up three
hundred and fifty percent compared to
last year they're dealing with isolation
they're stressed more stress than
they've ever been before
there's a lot of grieving and loss young
people who aren't able to connect with
their friends maybe they're missing
graduation and then we've also seen a
real increase in contacts around other
things like abuse and neglect so for
some young people home is not a safe
place the charity has called emergency
services around ten times a day during
the pandemic when needed to respond to a
suicide attempt and that need is
greatest in communities that were
already struggling the anxiety that
indigenous youth feel is heightened in a
lot of respects for for a number of
reasons I mean there isn't the same
access to health care in a lot of these
remote communities we're telling people
over and over again wash your hands wash
your hands but now we have a hundred or
so First Nations that are on water
advisories right now where that might
not be safe we've got poverty which is
affecting so many indigenous young
people and we don't have space to
socially isolate or physically isolate
within the home these things are causing
anxiety for young people faced with that
unprecedented need kids help phone
called for backup asking ordinary
Canadians to volunteer to provide
emotional support to anonymous strangers
over text message the charity's chief
youth officer admits it was a big ask we
put a call out we said hey people across
Canada raise your hand join us take a
training it's a 36-hour training they do
a police background check and then they
sign on to our platform and the response
was overwhelming we had almost nine
thousand Canadians raise their hand and
say that they wanted to be a part of
supporting young people which to me was
huge we are on track right now to
train more people in the next few weeks
than we have trained in the last two
years together one of those volunteer
crisis responders says it's a win-win
there's very few volunteer opportunities
I believe that you can walk at the end
of your shift or walk at the end your
day and say wow I've potentially saved
someone's life today and thanks to those
volunteers for the first time in its
history Kids Help Phone is now also
offering services to adults more and
more adults were coming to us and they
were starting the conversation with I'm
so sorry I'm not a kid or can I use the
service and we realize there aren't
enough places for adults who are also
going through the same distress the same
isolation it's a tough time but good
things are coming from it
Dunham's says they've also received a
large number of indigenous volunteers
offering to provide support to others in
need one of them is Ashley Cummings now
a member of the charity's indigenous
Advisory Council I feel like I'm doing
so much better now it definitely makes
me emotional knowing that a lot of other
youth are facing very similar or the
same kind of circumstances where they're
it just feels like there's too much I
think my message would be to just give
yourself one more day it's all about
those little baby steps that build up to
large feats of figuring out your mental
health
[Music]
anyone who needs mental health support
can call kids help phone at one eight
hundred six six eight six eight six
eight or text six eight six eight six
eight the service is available 24 hours
a day and as we mentioned it's for kids
and adults